major u.s airlines are warning of an
impending catastrophic crisis when a new
5g service is deployed by telecoms
giants at t and verizon on wednesday
american airlines delta united and
southwest airlines all say the new
technology might affect flight
instruments and render many aircraft
unusable that could lead to the
grounding of tens of thousands of
flights telecoms firms say they've
created buffer zones around airports but
the carriers warn that that won't be
enough
well let's discuss this more with
aviation journalist andrea spitz thanks
for joining us i just explained to us
this sounds pretty dramatic how
seriously uh are the airlines concerns
being taken
yeah actually i was a bit surprised too
this morning to learn of this letter
that uh the heads of the ten major u.s
airlines sent to the biden
administration last night apparently uh
in european time um this sounds really
dramatic so it's catastrophic tens of
thousands of americans might be stranded
overseas uh the domestic air system
might be it might have been thrown into
disarray from this development so this
is actually quite dramatic the question
is how serious is this actually going to
happen because it's tomorrow it's less
than one day away from us that this is
looming as the airlines say
interestingly this has been around as a
struggle between the telecommunications
industry and the aviation industry in
the us since some time because it was
almost a year ago that the u.s telecoms
companies actually got these awarded in
billions of dollars
auctions that they actually spent this
much money to get these frequencies
and the iron industry they are accusing
the iron industry of having delayed
their response so by now the faa the
american aviation authority has cleared
um about 48 out of 88 48 of 88 biggest
u.s airports to for this system to be
used like these new frequencies being
used close to the runways
so the question is really how many
aircraft will be affected and
right here what you say you stay close
to you say close to the runways that's
uh that's at t and verizon's argument
isn't it they say they've created buffer
zones around airports and they're not
too close to the runways why don't the
airlines believe them
that's the dispute the airlines actually
demand there will be a buffer zone with
none of these frequencies operating uh
in a radius of uh 3.7 kilometers or two
miles around the airport runways and
that's really the dispute that has not
been really implemented yet or they
didn't actually agree on this yet and
the telecommunications industry is
arguing that there are 40 other
countries where it does work without any
glitches um but of course like in europe
different frequencies are used so like
ersa here europe the european aviation
authority already said they didn't
detect any problems here but here the
the bands that are used for the 5g are a
bit different right so it's it's a
different territory
unknown territory well andreas spate
thank you for joining us on dw business
you're welcome